vier minuten möglichkeit zum justiz
haushalt stellung zu nehmen da fragt man
sich was erzählt man vor allem wenn man
noch der ausschussvorsitzende der herzen
ist ich hab mir gefragt habe ich gefragt
beginne ich so primitiv und niveaulos
wie gestern eine peinliche erscheinung
aus hamburg die jungs von der afg den
hals abschneiden wollte und sich in hass
und hetztiraden versteh ich hab ich mir
gesagt nein das dass ich sein wo der
verdiene ich mit verbots und anderen
fantasien betreffen die altparteien und
habe gedacht dass ich auch sein denn
verbieten von ihren für den altparteien
muss man niemandem meine damen und
herren sie werden sich selbst abschaffen
abschaffen sie schaffen sich schon
selber ganz da vorne dabei die spd vor
einiger zeit auch gerne noch von den
links neben ihnen sitzen als sozial
faschisten bezeichnet die spd nur noch
ein schatten ihrer selbst was angesichts
der programmatik und das politische
personal sind lichter in die erste reihe
das sich überwiegend aus alle glatten
karrieristen und ansonsten zumindest
schwer vermittelbaren rekrutiert das
verwundert nicht diese partei der
spezial demokraten meine damen und
herren die als sowas von fertig die
erledigt sich in kürze von selbst wobei
ich mich nicht festlegen möchte ob es
kurz oder vor der fdp und der linken
sein wird das werden wir sie machte spd
hingegen und da lege ich mich fest wird
den ehemals konservativen money kragen
gehen ich meine die cdu und die csu die
zu machtbesessenen und macht vergessenen
profillosen und inhaltsleeren
kanzlerinnen claqueuren versammeln
vollkommen sind danach kommen dann die
grünen dann die sich selber erledigen
werden diese überflüssige links
verschrobene polizei
die braucht kein mensch mehr nahmen sie
schaffen sich vor den altparteien
genauso wie sie schritt für schritt
unseren rechtsstaat abschaffen unsere
demokratie aushöhlen und grundrechte mit
den füßen treten in ihrem alltagsleben
loben und preisen sie den rechtsstaat
die demokratie und die meinungsfreiheit
auf der bundespräsident tut dass die
tägliche leben aber machen sie genau das
gegenteil sie verachten und bekämpfen
grundlegende prinzipien unseres
rechtsstaats und der demokratie zu
führen und tätscheln feinde unseres
freiheitlichen gemeinwesens sie fördern
linksextremismus und sie ignorieren
linksterrorismus meiner mutter sie
treten das grundgesetz mit den frühesten
stichwort artikel 3 absatz 3 politische
ansichten keine benachteiligung deshalb
in deutschland schlechter witz
kabarettisten werden unter druck gesetzt
ich nenne nur und steimle professoren
werden attackiert arbeitsplatzverluste
finden statt hessische filmförderung
journalisten werden drangsaliert wie
gewinner und nicht etwa weil sie eine
extrem er nein nur weil sie nicht
hundertprozentig auf ihn sind denn wenn
sie in der fdp sind da geht ihnen noch
schlimmer sie haben körperliche angriffe
zu erleiden angriffe auf häuser autos
angriffe auf gaststätten und hotels
schnüffeleien spitzeleien bedrohungen
dritter boykottaufrufe öffentliche
steckbriefe das ist der rechtsstaat den
sie zu boden berichten sie von den
altparteien die stigmatisieren
die grenzen auf die echten sozial das
ist das was im jahr 2019 im jahr 15 der
frau merkel
von deutschland über ist aber auch ein
sonst meine damen und herren ist unser
staat und einem desolaten zustand ich
denke mal dass man keine freudentränen
bei ihnen vorne sondern sie gehen
manchen sich und denken nach die sie
unser land vergewaltigt haben in den
letzten jahren das grundgesetz wird
gebogen und gebrochenen asylrecht
föderalismus europäisches recht
gebrochen euro-krise nullzinspolitik
dublin abkommen schengen abkommen
pleitestaaten finanzierung sie berechnen
gebote der gewaltenteilung die
verschleudern deutsches steuerzahlergeld
und trampeln auf der geschäftsordnung
des bundestages herum ich nenne nur die
vize präsidenten wahl
ich nenne die abwahl unbequemer
ausschussvorsitzender und jetzt wollen
sie auch noch die redezeiten begrenzen
im parlament nicht mehr die wahrheit
ausgesprochen merkt an sie wollen kein
parlament sie wollen ein abnicken des
schweiger mint das ist dass das
abendmahl nachdem aufgrund der kürze der
zeit waren das leider nur ein paar
wenige beispiele für den von ihnen von
der altparteien zu verantwortende ca und
schwer fall unseres landes unseres
ehemals stolzen rechtsstaates unserer
demokratie sie von den alpen sind ein
großer schaden ja teilweise eine schande
für dieses land meine damen mit der das
jeden tag wir deutschen aber haben viel
positives schädliches handeln für unser
land satt wir von der afg wollen und
werden den bürgern das zurückgeben was
sie verdienen nämlich einen
funktionierenden freiheitlichen
demokratischen rechtsstaat meiner mutter
dafür treten wir haben dafür wurden wir
gewählt und
für arbeiten hier vielen dank